Hello and welcome to this video where we're going to look at a couple of pre-made examples
of what can be done with procedural content generation. And the first example we're going
to look at is including PCG as a component to actor. Hello and if you come on to slide one,
example one, so that's the second one in our list here, you'll see that we have this
wooden this stone fence that comes around a park area. Now this is just an example how PCG can be
used as a component of a all but blueprint. Now we'll look through this relatively quickly,
but I'll sort of demonstrate it here. So if I was to drag in the park wall at this point,
what you would see is we have our park and on either side of this is a
spline. Like we've done with the path before, we have a spline mesh here which we could use
in exactly the same way. We can create a park and we have two splines, so we've done it twice
here at this point, and we are able to add spline points, move different areas around,
and the wall is going to conform to or do as best it can to conform to those spline points.
It allows us to easily create some kind of park. There are also a couple of other settings here,
so with it if you select the overall thing you can see that we have the ability to turn the sign
off and it will remove the gates or even to open the gates so that we can
get any kind of effect we're looking to achieve. Now this is just an example of how
it could be used as an asset in order to put together a level. Now if we open up the blueprint
for the the park wall, let's have a quick look at the code that is attached.
It's relatively straightforward. We have the ability to refresh the gate and the code that
we have here is pretty much all about opening the gates and destroying components dependent on
the buttons that are pushed. The PCG doesn't actually require any specific code beyond
creating a spline with wall right. So we're using the same spline for both of them.
And we have a PCG component. So if we look at the PCG component, again it's very very simple.
All that it's doing is it's getting the spline data but this time we are doing it as self.
If you remember in our example previously we were looking in the world for this,
this is only reacting to the splines which are part of this actor. So this makes it a very
nice sort of short point of comparison. It's just getting the splines and then at certain points
down the spines it is going to place a static mesh. So one of them is the in-between section
and the other section and the other one is the metal fence. And the nice thing is
we have the one with the brick wall here but we also have just a wall on its own.
So this functions in exactly the same way. See we can create an extra fence and add spline points
to build this out. If I was to look at that we have no code at all. There's no code needed
in the slightest. We just have the splines with the ability to find them
and we have the PCG added in. So it's really really straightforward and simple.
We can even set the meshes as a parameter as an input or something else and you can make
these more and more complicated. But I like this as just a very very short example of how
you can very quickly procedurally add meshes to an actor. Which if you've tried this programmatically
before it's quite complicated. You have to break down a spline and figure out where the
meshes need to be at one point. So this is a really nice quick way of achieving the same kind
of thing. Thank you very much and in the next video we'll jump on to the next example.